Das Podcast du vor, Comedy Spaß, Spaß, Comedy Spaß, melde Tini und Sitzler, manchmal noch ernst, aber Spaß, hauptsächlich Spaß. Das ist komisch, wir konnten das beide mitsingen schon, weil es so lange schon rumliegt und wir haben auf die richtige Folge gewartet. Spaß, hauptsächlich Spaß.
Hauptsächlich Spaß.
Also die Idee des Wort hauptsächlich in Intro zu packen. In Comedy-Intro. Genial. Obacht, jetzt kommt Spaß. Gummibären lösen hauptsächlich Abenteuer, aber nebensächlich auch klar. Hauptsächlich in der Hauptsache Abenteuer. Ja, vielen Dank an Yannis für dieses fantastische Intro. Vielen Dank, es ist erfüllt uns. In der Regel wäre noch besser. Meistens. In der Regel Spaß, manchmal auch ernst. Warum muss man sowas einbringen in ein Intro? Ist ein Intro nicht immer, genau wie Jingles, immer positiv? Dieses manchmal auch ernst wirkt so ein bisschen so entschuldigend. Jede zweite Folge
ist ganz gut, hier ist das
hauptsächlich gut. Im Rest
kann man sich sparen.
Im Grunde schon, ich weiß es nicht genau.
Es gibt auch keine Werbe-Jingles,
die so einen Tick negativ werden.
Es ist immer
freundlich, es ist nie negativ.
Ich werde angerufen.
Oh, der Herr Producer
ist leider wichtig.
Dann geh doch mal ran. Okay, es wird ernst.
Er ist... immer, das ist nie negativ, ich werde angerufen. Oh, der Herr Producer ist leider wichtig, dann geh doch mal ran, okay, es wird ernst, er hat sich den Kopfhörer vom Kopf gerissen und läuft zum Fenster, oh, er merkt, dass er beim Fenster nicht weit genug von mir entfernt ist, läuft jetzt nochmal ganz um den Tisch außenrum, sucht jetzt seinen Schlüssel und er guckt mal kurz einen Moment, er muss kurz rübergehen. Er schließt die Tür, ich muss abbrechen, sagt er. Da gibt er mit den Befehl, er ist ja Executive Producer vom Podcast Ufo, muss man dazu sagen. Das heißt, er hat die Befehlsgewalt, er kann die Aufnahme beenden, er läuft jetzt über den Hof mit dem Handy am Ohr. Das sieht schon sehr, sehr professionell aus. Also das muss man schon sagen. Da hat sich der Stefan auch weiterentwickelt. Also innerhalb der ersten, was sind wir jetzt, Minute zwei des Podcast-Ufos, normalerweise rufen die immer nach der Aufnahme an, aber jetzt schon zwei Minuten nach Beginn, da muss er los, auch direkt die Flucht zum Fenster. Ich glaube, wenn man das Telefon klingelt, man will automatisch zum Fenster. Ich glaube, das ist so ein unterbewusst angeborener Drang, einfach irgendwie die Schallwellen oder die Funkwellen aufzusaugen, die da kommen von den Sendemästen, die ja über ganz Deutschland verteilt sind, die man manchmal sehen kann, wenn das Wetter gut ist. Und Stefan hat sich da intuitiv ans Fenster begeben, um da auch aufzusaugen, um zu wissen, was will Mr. Jakamoto, der gerade am anderen Ende der Leitung kurz davor ist, den großen Deal abzuschließen, aber natürlich nochmal Stefans Erlaubnis braucht. Das ist klar, da geht gar nichts ohne Stefan, ohne Titzesan ist da nichts möglich in Hongkong. Deswegen ruft er an, oh jetzt kommt er zurück an, jetzt kommt er zurückgerannt, kein Handy mehr in der Hand, er rennt, mal gucken, vielleicht hat er den Schlüssel vergessen, er hat ja vorhin den Schlüssel mitgenommen, er ist einfach voraussichtlich. Jetzt wird er ein bisschen außer Atem sein, aber das muss jetzt halt einfach sein, das muss jetzt einfach sein, das wird ihm auch unglaublich leicht tun, aber das muss jetzt halt mal kurz sein. Und ja, Stefan, schön, dass du Zeit gefunden hast hier für die Podcast-UFO-Aufnahme. Meine Schwester ist gestorben. Schon wieder? Nee, sorry. Ach, aber ich bin kurz mal sauer. Die wissen alle, dass wir hier einen professionellen Podcast aufnehmen, dass wir hier professionell jede Woche Comedy-Feuerwerke abfackeln. Hauptsächlich Comedy. Hauptsächlich Comedy-Feuerwerke. Manchmal nehmen sie auf, aber hauptsächlich nicht telefonieren. Manchmal löschen sie die Episode, aber meistens tun sie es nicht. Komm mal runter jetzt erstmal. Ist es warm? Warm. Ist es warm? Es ist warm. Es ist wirklich warm draußen geworden. Kannst du was dazu sagen? Du hast ja, ich meine, ich möchte ja immer so jede Woche so ein bisschen was wegkratzen, so von der gefrorenen Windschutzscheibe, die Stefan Stiezes Leben ist. Du willst das Ice-Breaken? Ich will das Ice-Breaken. Ich habe so eine alte CD-Hülle noch irgendwie, ACDC hat mal vor drei Jahren Mitfahrer mitgenommen, hängt jetzt natürlich noch im Handschuhfach und jetzt kratze ich langsam ab. Du entwickelst ja gerade eine Serie, kann man das so sagen. Kann man so sagen, ja. Wo in diesem Entwicklungsprozess, also da geht's ja irgendwann los und irgendwann hört's auf, an welchem Punkt sagt man, okay Freunde, wir haben ein ultra krass durchgestyltes Intro mit geiler Musik, geilen Visuals, das so dreieinhalb Minuten geht. Oder man sagt, nee, wir machen schon einfach den Namen der Sendung und so ein ... Ja. Wo? Also es gibt ja nur diese beiden Extremen, es gibt nichts dazwischen. Wann trifft man die Entscheidung? Genau, tatsächlich gab es diese Entscheidung schon. So viel kann ich sagen. Also es ist aber mehr so ein, naja, dann werden ja auch Grafiker, die dann irgendwie so ein Moodboards, wo die Main-Titles irgendwie, wo du willst irgendwann... Langsam. Irgendwann fängst du an die Grafik... Wir müssen Untertitel für den Podcast anbringen. Ich bring so einen Flyer, krieg dir. Das Ding ist ja, du musst irgendwann das Grafikdepartment involvieren. Die haben aber von der ganzen Machen wir das zwei Sekunden lang Intro? Also ist dann die Frage, machen wir Better Call Saul? Ja, oder Breaking Bad? Oder Breaking Bad, oder machen wir Game of Thrones? Ja. Also wirklich die epische Nummer, oder einfach nur den kurzen Babam. Ja. Und dann wird ja jedenfalls das Grafikdepartment involviert, und die haben dann davon noch nichts mitbekommen, und die machen dann so ein Moodboard, wie das theoretisch aussehen könnte. Ah, also die schlagen dann was vor. Genau. Und das sieht dann immer so gut aus, dass man sagt, okay, zehn Minuten Intro. Komm, wir machen zehn bis zwölf Minuten Intro. Das heißt aber dann rückwirkend, bei Breaking Bad haben die so schlechte Arbeit geleistet, dass sie gesagt haben, nee, einfach für die Dramaturgie ein bisschen kürzer. Völlig richtig. Und dann irgendwann entscheidet man sich, was sieht dann richtig gut aus, muss man sagen, und dann will man auch irgendwie, man will sich auch nicht, und das merkt man auch manchmal, man will sich nicht für einen Stil entscheiden. Und das, finde ich, merkt man bei Game of Thrones total. Die haben zum einen dieses, es bildet sich so eine Modellstadt und dann dieses typische Fantasy-Feuerring. Beides haben die ja. Erst bildet sich diese Modellstadt und dann fanden die aber auch noch diese Feuerring-Idee ganz gut. Und dann kommt der Feuerring und dann kommt Game of Thrones groß und so. Und dennoch, dass in den Namen so die chemischen Elemente so eingebunden sind. Das fanden die auch geil. Das fand ich dann ab Staffel fünf ein bisschen merkwürdig. Ich finde, das hat mich bei Game of Thrones immer schon aufgeregessen. Zwei Stile einfach, die in diesem Intro zusammenkommen. Ich denke mir, bleibt doch einfach bei eurem, die Modellstadt baut sich auf. Übrigens lustigerweise haben die bei der WM jetzt in Russland, haben die als Intro für die WM haben die einfach das Game of Thrones-Intro nachgebaut.
Muss man auch sagen, eine Serie, die seit vier Jahren nicht mehr cool ist.
Also hätten die ja nicht irgendwas, was frisches, was peppiges machen können, so wie Dark, so ein bisschen saftig, nass, so ein bisschen Untergrund, so das Unterholz.
So wie Dark? Meinst du die Serie Dark?
Ja.
Meinst du die gerade?
Ja, zum Beispiel.
Das war zu frisch.
Das sind drauf, was so frisch.
Oh, die stecken in den Augen, aus dem sehr kleinen Top von Stefan Tietze. Nein, frisch im Sinne von saftig. Saftig? Im Sinne von saftig. Die haben ja diesen Regenlook, da regnet es ja die ganze Zeit. Das stimmt, das ist mir auch sehr. Deswegen dieses saftige Moos verbinde ich damit. Nicht angenehm, nicht frisch, aber saftig. Einfach so ein ...
Feucht, kann man sagen. Schwül. Ja, so ein ... Ja, genau. Schwüles Intro. Schwüles Intro. Schwüles Intro. Bestes Serien-Intro? Hatten wir, glaube ich, schon vier Mal. Oh, beste Serien-Intro! In vier Folgen hat man jedes Mal diese Frage. Das beste Serien-Intro. Oh, okay. American Gods. American Gods ist ein Intro, was ich mir wirklich noch ein paar Mal danach auf YouTube angeguckt habe. Ich fand True Detective am besten. Das habe ich mir auch schon ein paar Mal auf YouTube angeguckt. Naja. Und man merkt immer bei deutschen Serien, beziehungsweise dann so bei ZDF und Sat.1 Film, Filmen, Filmen, merkt man dann, dass die oft sagen, das finde ich ganz geil, diesen Style, den die da haben bei True Detective, mache ich auch bei unserem Film. Und dann ist es immer so ein Abklatsch, aber natürlich passt das Inhaltliche überhaupt nicht dazu. Weil es ist natürlich interessant, dass in den Köpfen oft dann, also dass True Detective total mit der Umgebung spielt und mit den Landschaften, in der sie sind und mit den verschiedenen Menschen da sind und diesen kaputten Welten und Mikrokosmen. Und in dem Moment, wo du dann guckst, dass es irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, um einen Film geht, wo die Schwiegermutter mit dem Feuerwehrmann durchbrennt, dass dann da auch plötzlich mit diesen Silhouetten gearbeitet wird und so Stock-Footage-Bildern im Hintergrund, wo man sich auch fragt, muss es sein. Hast du ein paar Tipps, wie man eine Serie entwickelt, worauf muss man achten, wie schafft man es, dass es spannend bleibt?
Das möchte ich erst beantworten, wenn die Serie raus ist und sie gut geworden ist.
Wenn der Rotten Tomato, vor allem, du kriegst ja Serienempfehlungen auf allen Plattformen und auf allen, du kriegst ja Serienempfehlungen vorgeschlagen.
Ich frage mich, die Serie, die ich gerade entwickle, was ich da für einen Score bekomme.
Ja, und welchen Leuten wird die vorgeschlagen werden? Was steht da drunter dann? Ich kann noch nicht so viel verraten. Also die Rezeption der Serien hat sich ja stark entwickelt und es ist ja immer, also es geht ja wahnsinnig viel um Cliffhanger und um Spoiler und Plot und ah, da tut sich nichts. Wenn man mal so eine Serie wie Sopranos anschaut oder so, wo man das Gefühl hat,
die wurde ganz anders entwickelt, da ging es nicht
um, oh, Spoiler mich auf gar keinen Fall
und oh, große Cliffhanger, so hier und da
schon mal, aber irgendwie hat man das Gefühl,
dass man jetzt so in jeder Folge muss
irgendwas Megakrasses passieren und damit
alle am nächsten Tag im Büro drüber reden
und jede Folge muss am Ende ultra
den Megacliffhanger haben.
Ich freue mich schon darauf, wenn ich darüber reden darf. Ja, aber muss man da so auch reingehen, oder sagt man ... So und so. Es liegt natürlich total an dir und an dem Writer's Room und an den Leuten, was sie für Entscheidungen treffen und was sie für den Geschmack haben. Aber du kriegst da auch teilweise Anmerkungen, die interessant sind. Lass uns da nicht drüber reden. Du, wie gesagt, jede Woche kratzt sich ein bisschen was ab. Es gibt keine es gibt, wie viele Folgen wir darüber machen werden, über die Insider-Informationen, die du ja auch gerade sammelst. Du hast ja auch in der Zwischenzeit schon einen Film gedreht, wo du in einem Trailer gewohnt hast. Das kann man ja auch mal sagen. Dass du in einem Trailer gewohnt hast. Wie gut ist das denn? In einem Trailer, da hing ein Gemälde, Bild, da hing auf der einen Seite ein Fernseher, also ein Wohnwagen. Ich habe jetzt erst an einem Trailer, so einem Filmtrailer gedacht. Teaser. Und erst auf der einen Seite war ein Fernseher, auf der anderen Seite hing ein Bild und das Bild hing falsch rum. Ja. Wo ich mir auch dachte, okay, das ist so ein David-Lynch-Set wahrscheinlich. Bei David-Lynch-Set ist alles so, da hängt die Sofa an der Decke und jeder hat sofort so Mindfucks, sobald man die Gebäude nur betritt. Aber da war es einfach nur ein Fehler. Aber naja, je nachdem. Unterschiedlich. Aber tatsächlich, Drama ist ja wichtig. Und ich muss auch sagen, ich schaue gerade Harry Potter. Du schaust Harry Potter. Harry Potter? Schau ich gerade an. Und ist dir mal aufgefallen,
was Dumbledore für ein Arschloch ist?
Wie ist das Arschloch. Dumbledore ist ein völlig unnötiges Arschloch. Nee, Mentor. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Klassischer Mentor. Kleines Beispiel, ja. Ich meine, Folge, was sagt man, sagt man Episode bei Harry Potter oder Teil? Teil, ne? Kapitel. Episode sagt man nur bei Star Wars und Teil sagt man bei Harry Potter. Bei? Und Herr der Ringe Teil 1. Herr der Ringe Episode 1, da würde jeder sagen, wovon redest du? Herr der Ringe, weiter geht's. Weiter geht's und jetzt noch einmal. Da muss man sagen, bei Fast and Furious und Too Fast, Too Furious, haben die schon gut gemacht? Three Fast, Three Furious, Leute. Oder wie ich tatsächlich einen extrem guten Einwand von Dan Harmon finde. Ja, ich weiß auch, was du meinst. Ja, dann? Now You See Me heißt der erste Teil. Genau, der Film hieß Now You See Me und der zweite Teil hieß Now You See Me Too. Ja. Was ein Quatsch. Warum heißt der nicht Now You Don't? Now You See Me, Now You Don't. Und es ist ein Magierfilm. Natürlich muss der zweite Now You Don't heißen. Ja, ich meine, ich kann natürlich auch schon verstehen, warum man sagt, man kann nicht einen Film veröffentlichen, der Now You Don't.
Das ist halt so ein bisschen dieses irgendwie Look at me when one is watching Ding, so ein, aber im Endeffekt.
Naja, zum Beispiel Teil vier, ja, Film, wir wissen alle, mittelmässig bis zur Szene, bis zur Szene mit
Genau, der Hogwarts-March. Und die Szene mit ... Du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-okus. Und wir kommen in einem Schiff, ein normales Schiff, nope, das kommt von unter dem Wasser, und ihr, Ryanair. Wir haben ein bisschen billigen Flug geschossen da. Saurow. Sau teure Sandwiches am Flughafen, bis heute das war auch. Das war auch die normalen. Auch, dass sie bei King's Cross starten und nicht einfach London Heathrow einfach schön am Gate stehen. Gate neun dreiviertel. Ah, guck mal, das ist jetzt ein Secret. Hätte man nicht auch einfach Harvard einladen können. So eine Muggelschule, so Leute. Ein Professor ist ein Muggeltyp, der hat es einfach drauf in Mathe, muss man mal ganz ehrlich sagen. Ist nicht so, dass die rechnen können. Und damit herzlich willkommen zu, Antanaska war Nummer zwei. Aber worauf ich hinaus will, da sind ja die anderen Schulen zu Gast in Hogwarts. Das heißt, Hogwarts will sich gut darstellen als guter Gastgeber und natürlich am Ende das grosse Final des Trimagischen Turniers. Alle sind da, und die Blaskapelle spielt natürlich in Hogwarts. Da, da, da, da, da, da, die Blaskapelle spielt natürlich. Und nachts kommt der Remix. Gibt es einen Remix? Ne, glaube ich nicht. Und auf jeden Fall, die Kapelle spielt und was passiert dann? Während die Kapelle spielt, sagen die Leute, fuck it, wir fangen einfach an und gehen in das Labyrinth rein. Nee, Dumbledore kommt und sagt, aus, aus, aus, Ruhe, Ruhe, aus. Ja, wirklich. Und hält dann seine Rede. Wo ich mir denke, warum? Warum kannst du nicht einfach die Blaskapelle zu Ende spielen lassen? Ich meine, jemand hat sich diese Zeremonie ja ausgedacht. Erst spielt die Blaskapelle, dann kommt die Rede von Dumbledore. Nope, Blaskapelle spielt und Dumbledore aus, aus, aus, aus, aus, aus!
Das muss jetzt nicht mehr rein!
Was ist denn dein Scheissproblem?
Er war da schon tot, er hat schon dieses schwarze Mal, was sich in ihm ...
Das wird alles ...
Geil. Nicht so schlecht. Sehr schön. Ja, das stimmt schon. Vor allem, ich meine, und vor allem ... Aus Teil drei, der beste Harry Potter. Ja. Wirklich der beste. Es fängt schon super an, wie er inszeniert ist, dass die Kamera durch die große Halle quasi schwebt und dann an diesem Chor landet. Ja, der Froschchor. Der Frötenchor, ja. Und dann wird der so getracht, aber der darf aussingen. Warum dürfen die zu Ende singen? Warum trauen diese Fröschenjüter auf? Warum singen die mit? Ich meine, die haben singende Frösche? Nee, die singen ja nicht mit, die machen die Quaken dabei. Ach ja, stimmt. Warum sagt man hier einfach, hör auf zu quaken, das stört. Ja, und vor allem, warum haben das Menschen, also Muggels nie gemacht? Warum sind, also in der Fantasy-Welt die magischen Zauberer sind die Ersten, die auf die Idee gekommen sind, Frösche zu kröten? Das Harry Potter-Universum ist ein Universum, wo es Zauberer gibt und wo alle Chöre mit Fröschen singen. Das waren die beiden Prämissen, die auf die Rowling gepocht hat. Leute, ich will mein Buch schreiben, und ich schreib's nur, wenn diese zwei Prämissen erfüllt sind.
Und der Saturn existiert auch nicht. Das hat ein Throwback-Gag von letzter Woche.
Und alle Juden haben sechs Finger. Okay, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam.
Und dann wird der Schwul. Okay, hau, hau, hau, hau.
Aber ich mein, das ist die Eröffnung dieses Turniers. Die haben Zeit. Die haben keinen Zeitdruck. Es ist geplant, er spielt die Musik, dann hält Dumbledore die Rede. Aber er kommt rein. Stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, es ist einfach, es ist einfach, es ist einfach, es ist einfach, es ist einfach, es ergibt keinen Sinn, wo ich mir denke, was hat der Regisseur, was hat der Regisseur, dem Dumbledore, dem Dumbledore, dem Dumbledore, dem Dumbledore, dem Dumbledore, dem Dumbledore, dem D Regisseur dem Dumbledore-Schauspiel gesagt zu ihr? Du rennst jetzt raus und beendest die Kapelle. Du bist ein Arschloch. Warum? Du spielst ein schwules Arschloch. Warum? Das ist mein Dreamings. Okay, immer noch getragen. Das kann auch noch auf der Wiesn gespielt werden, das fällt nicht auf. Jetzt kommt gleich der Drop. Ich glaube nicht. Einfach unarrangelliert.
Das ist der schönste Teil.
Aber tatsächlich, ich wollte gerade sagen, wir leben gerade in einer genialen Phase, in der man auf YouTube für jeden Scheiss sofort gebannt und gesperrt wird wegen Urheberrecht, bei Podcasts nichts.
Wir könnten jetzt hier einfach I Can Get No Satisfaction spielen und es würde nichts passieren, gar nichts. Okay. Okay. Challenge accepted. Wir müssen auch noch mal Antenne Asgaban machen und wir müssen auch noch Antenne Apu machen und den ganzen anderen Kram. Antenne Auenland. Das machen wir immer wirklich. Es geht da weiter, wo ich nicht gedacht hätte, dass es da nochmal weitergeht. Ich lebe meinen Abend so vor mich hin und plötzlich bekomme ich eine Mail. Pling! Oh, ich werde aus meinem Schlaf gerissen. Du hast Alexa schon gute Nacht gesagt. Ich habe Alexa gute Nacht gesagt. Es liegt noch so ein bisschen Fernsehen im Hintergrund.
Und dann kommt eine Mail rein. Ich dachte mir,
was, das kann doch nicht sein.
Ich habe mich verlesen. Nein, die WC-Ente
hat noch mal geschrieben. Nein, Teil
zwei. SC Johnson & Son.
Ist es SC Johnson
persönlich gewesen?
Vorher hat er Sohn geschrieben, jetzt hat er SC Johnson persönlich geschrieben.
Um ganz kurz nochmal zusammenfassen.
Wir haben eine Nachricht geschrieben an WC-Ente und haben uns beschwert, dass die WC-Ente nicht wie eine Ente aussieht, sondern wie ein Schwan. Hört Podcast chronologisch. Dadurch kamen mehrere Leute, die sich beschwert haben. Die ersten haben gesagt, Schwäne sind auch Enten, was schon mal unser erster Fehler war. Zweitens haben die uns geantwortet und gesagt, na für uns sieht das aus wie eine Ente, haben sie gesagt. Auch in Libia-Legge und sich fragt, was soll das denn? Die Frage ist, was kommt jetzt noch? Also, ich weiss jetzt auch nicht. Ich glaube, ich habe es aus Versehen zweimal abgeschickt, ich bin mir nicht sicher. Je nachdem, Ahmad El Hussein schreibt. Sehr geehrter Herr Tietze, selbstverständlich bin ich ihm sehr gerne behilflich. Wir haben mehrere Kollegen, und jetzt wird es wieder ein bisschen böse, muss man sagen. Es wird wieder, bin es nur ich oder hört ihr auch diesen Unterton? Wir haben mehrere Kollegen, die in der Produktions-Design-Abteilung arbeiten und mitbestimmen. Solange das Unternehmen oder die Abteilung der Meinung ist, dass dies das perfekte Design perfekt großgeschrieben ist, dann ist das leider so. Wir können das Design nicht einfach ändern. Für SC Johnson ist dies das perfekte wieder großgeschrieben Endendesign. Trotzdem werde ich Ihnen Hinweise gerne weiterleiten und vielleicht wird sich ja doch was an der Flasche ändern in Zukunft. Stopp, stopp, stopp, das muss ich sehen. Wenn Sie Fragen haben oder weitere Informationen benötigen, kontaktieren Sie das grossgeschrieben. Okay, aber nicht in Versalien, sondern das P ist gross. Es ist nicht komplett in Capitals, das P ist gross. Okay, okay, aber dann hätte er dich ja direkt verarscht, weil du ja auch Sachen in Caps geschrieben hast. Aber wie gut ist das denn? Für SC Johnson ist dies das perfekte Entendesign. Trotzdem werde ich Ihren Hinweis gerne weiterleiten. Okay, das wird weitergeleitet, intern wird es weitergeleitet, auf Wiedervorlage. Und vielleicht wird sich ja doch was in der Flasche in Zukunft ändern. Ja, wie wär's denn mit dem WC in Schwan? Ja, das frage ich dich. Wär der WC Schwan? Man muss sagen, die erste Antwort, die kam, war sehr defensiv. Das stimmt, ja. Und sehr abblockend auch. Da war nicht sowas wie, ja, danke für den Input, vielleicht sind wir mehr weiter. Und das sagt übrigens unser Chef SC Johnson dazu. Ja. Jetzt kommt zurück, heisst das übrigens WC Duck woanders? SC Johnson, das kommt ja nicht aus Deutschland. Also mal ganz kurz, ist dir gerade klar, dass wir gerade in der Möglichkeit stehen, dass die WC-Ente in WC-Schwan umgenannt wird? Nein, nein, nein, nein, das ist nicht das, was er vorsteigt. Vielleicht wird sich ja doch was an der Flasche ändern in Zukunft. Ach so, das heißt, es kann sein, dass wir jetzt dafür verantwortlich sind, dass die WC-Ente einen richtigen Entenhals bekommt und deswegen nicht mehr geeignet ist, um damit Klos sauber zu machen. Ja, oder dass es wirklich so auch doch, also wirklich so nachgebildet ist, der Schnabel einer Ente und so Federn kriegt. Ja, und man kann die Flasche nicht mehr benutzen und alle Kunden werden sauer. Also, ich sehe zwei Lösungen. Entweder das Ding wird unbindert in WC-Schwan. Ja, das ist auch das Einzige, was wir wollen. Oder es sieht mehr aus wie eine Ente. Ja, entweder es sieht mehr aus wie eine Ente, dann ist aber eure ganze Idee, die ganze Geschäftsidee hinfällig, oder ihr lennst einfach fucking WC-Schwan, das ist das, wofür wir plädieren. Kannst du die nochmal vorlesen, bitte? Sehr geehrter Herr Tietze, selbstverständlich bin ich Ihnen sehr gerne behilflich. Wir haben mehrere Kollegen, die in der Produktdesign-Abteilung arbeiten und mitbestimmen. Solange das Unternehmen oder die Abteilung der Meinung ist, dass dies das perfekte Design ist, dann ist das leider so. Leider so. Wir können das Design nicht einfach ändern. Aber das klingt so, als hätte er es versucht, anzustoßen. Ja, als wären ihm die Hände gebunden, als wäre er auf unserer Seite auf einer Art. Ja, das klingt so. Adam Hussein ist auf unserer Seite. Man muss sagen, das ist leider so. Wir können das Design nicht einfach ändern. Warum nicht? Aber da ist schon viel Zugeständnis drin. Warum denn nicht? Warum können die das Design nicht ändern? Der hat doch mehrere Kollegen, sagt er. Die können das doch auch wieder ändern. Mehrere Kollegen, Punkt. Das ist die schlechteste Verteidigung aller Zeiten. Ich habe mehrere Kollegen, die auch meiner Meinung sind. Schlechter Anwalt. Für SC Johnson ist dies das, aber da muss man sagen, dann nimmt er den Film doch noch einen Schatz. Ja, ja Schatz. Für SC Johnson ist dies das perfekte Entendesign. Trotzdem werde ich Ihren Hinweis gerne weiterleiten und vielleicht wird es in Zukunft ändern. Naja, ich finde, wir kommen Schritt für Schritt weiter. Zwei Chancen, dem müssen wir jetzt antworten. Also erstes Mal soll er auf jeden Fall mit maximaler Inbrunst dieses Thema weiter verteidigen und ich sehe, eigentlich gibt es zwei Lösungen. Erstens W.C. Schwan. Sehr geehrter. Zweitens, das muss ich erinnern, W.C. Schwan, der Schwan ist nämlich ein Entenvogel. Damit wären sie nämlich gar nicht so weit weg. Sehr geehrter Ahmad El Hussein, zunächst erstmal grosse Sorry, Schwäne sind auch Entenvögel. Ja, das war uns nicht klar. Das müssen wir eingestehen. Wir müssen auch mit offenen Karten stehen. Ich möchte mit einem Eingeständnis beginnen. Vielen Dank, aber vielen Dank für Ihre nette Antwort. Für Ihre nette Antwort. Für Ihre perfekte Antwort. Ich schreib's gross. Perfekte Antwort. Zunächst einmal, Doppelpunkt, grosses Sorry. In der Zwischenzeit haben wir herausgefunden, wir? Ich, denk dran, Familie Tietz aus im sonnigen Köln schreibt, meine Frau und ich herausgefunden.
Ich will so ein Familienidyll aufmachen, wo die beiden nicht...
Haben meine Frau und ich herausgefunden, was die Familie den ganzen Tag macht, dass Enten auch Schwäne, nee, Schwäne auch Entenvögel sind. Immer dieser Fehler, Fehler, Schwäne auch Entenvögel sind. Das war uns so nicht bewusst. Erstaunlich. Erstaunlich? Haben Sie das gewusst? Erstaunlich. Erstaunlich, das war uns so nicht bewusst. Ihnen? Um Antwort wird gebeten Ihnen um Antwort mit gebeten. Dann zicke ich zu früh ab und dann zicke ich dann noch eine Mail. Oh, ich wusste nicht, dass es schon sendet, wenn man auf Senden klickt. Das ist mir in der Tat oft passiert, weil ich mittlerweile diesen neuen MacBook habe, der oben diese Leiste hat. Die ist primär dazu da, dass man in peinlichen Situationen, wenn man in so einem Mailstreits ist. Ich bin oft in den Mailstreiz. Und dann plötzlich macht man ja manchmal so Entwürfe, wo man dann schon mal sagt, ey, die muss ich schreiben, folgende Argumente muss ich in Kräften. Und dann kommt man auf Senden und denkt sich, das ist jetzt scheiße. Dann sehen die das Skalett. Ja, und jetzt sind die massiven Streitigkeiten. Erstaunlich, das war uns so nicht bewusst. Ihm, naja, wie dem auch sei. Für uns gibt es eigentlich nur zwei Möglichkeiten. Für uns gibt es nach ihrer Mail eigentlich nur zwei Möglichkeiten. Römisch erstens. Und dann B. Römisch eins. Weißt du, wie ich mir das vorstelle, so ein Pädagogen-Ehepaar, die auch schon in Ruhestand sind, aber kleine Kinder-Arontiere. Römisch erstens, ihr Produkt wird unbenannt im WC-Schwan. Ihr Produkt wird unbenannt. Klingt doch ganz gut, oder? Im WC-Schwan. Hat einen netten, klingt freundlich. Hat doch was, oder? Oder, da frage ich jetzt ihn. Da kennen sich ihre Kollegen jetzt besser aus. Hat das was? Da kennen sich Ihre Kollegen vielleicht besser aus. Römisch zwei, ich schreibe sie mal aus. Römisch zwei. Ich weiss nicht, auf welchem Punkt er sich verarscht fühlt. Ich mache zwei grosse I, wie sich für einen anständigen Menschen gehört. Haben die auch schon gewusst, dass sie zwei grosse Is schreiben eigentlich? Oder waren sie sich bewusst, dass es gerade ein Zwei? Haben die sich gefühlt, als ob sie gerade I, I schreiben? Oder hat sich für die angefühlt wie zwei? Oder dass sie manchmal so Sachen lesen. Also man schreibt ja manchmal Too Fast, Too Furious, schreibt eine Zwei. Aber wenn die jetzt parallel, dann lesen die nur eine zwei, die Römer,
und denken sich, hä, die checkt das Wortspiel gerade nicht.
Para zwei, was?
Was soll das sein, Para zwei?
Protoss!
Römisch zwei.
Sie ändern das Design, so dass es eine Ente ...
Finde ich gut, wenn wir den Tipp geben, wie sie es machen.
Vielleicht halten sie eine Ente daneben, Fragezeichen. Hier das Bild einer Ente, finde ich gut, wenn wir den Tipp geben, wie Sie es machen. Vielleicht halten Sie eine Ente daneben, Fragezeichen.
Hier das Bild einer Ente. Anbei ein schönes Entenbild. Vor allem, ich war neulich, am vergangenen Wochenende war ich im Zoo. Und dann gab es tatsächlich... Alleine? Nee. Aha, mit wem? Mit Katjana. Ich war im Zoo und dann gibt es die Dampfschiffente. Und zwar muss man sagen, es ist unsere Standardente. Ja. Hat vielleicht ein paar andere Farben. Dampfschiffente. Und deren Ente ... Nee, Dampfschiffente. Dampfschiff. Und deren Ente ... Das sieht doch aus wie Dampfschiffe, das sieht doch aus, Magda, das sieht doch aus wie kleine Dampfschiffe, oder nicht? Ja, vor allem wurden Enten erst nach Dampfschiffen benannt. Was haben denn die Leute im Mittelalter gesagt? Die Dampfschiffe wurden nach Enten benannt. Sieht aus wie eine große Ente. Also haben Leute im Mittelalter gesagt, das ist eine, ja halt. Und deswegen aber, ich fand es so lustig, dass die Ente ... Können wir kurz darüber reden, dass man keine Bilder mehr kopieren kann bei Google? Ja, ui. Die leiten nur noch weiter auf die Seiten, von denen sie sind. Und dieses Entengehege war direkt neben dem Leopardengehege. Oh, shit. Und da denke ich mir auch, wenn du als Ente checkst, dass du als Default hier, warum setzt du uns neben den fucking Leoparden? Wir sind Leopard, wir sind Enten. Setz uns nach vorne, damit man bei uns steht. Naja, aber die Denkweise ist ja völlig klar. Alle wollen die Leoparden sehen, und niemand geht bewusst zu den Enten. Aber dann lass doch alle die Ente in Ruhe. Macht unser Gehege neben das Klo, damit die Familienväter da warten müssen und uns angucken müssen. Naja, aber so ein Zoo ist ja aufgebaut wie die Tastatur, dass häufige Buchstaben nicht neben selten benutzen Buchstaben liegen. Und genauso ist es bei Zoos auch, da sind die coolen Tiere durchmischt mit langweiligen Tieren. Okay. Also zweiter, das Design wird geändert. Im Anhang. Anbei. Anbei. Im Anhang. Einbei das Bild einer Ente. Eines Erpels. Eine Ente habe ich nicht gefunden. Einbei das Bild einer Ente. Sorry für das Wasserzeichen. Das Wasserzeichen habe ich nicht rausbekommen. Vielleicht daneben halten. Daneben halten. aber unsicher. Das versteht man. Versteht man, was gemeint ist damit? Vielleicht einmal daneben halten, vielleicht einmal ausdrucken und daneben halten. Vielleicht einmal ausdrucken und daneben halten. In Klammern, Steuerung P, nervig werden. Vielleicht einmal ausdrucken und danehalten, in Fragezeichen. Nicht Punkt, das ist zu übergriffig.
Ja, ja.
Nebenhalten?
Vielleicht funktioniert die WC entweder sogar noch besser.
Nicht falsch verstehen, wir sind sehr zufrieden.
Nochmal.
Vielleicht funktioniert es dann sogar besser.
Auf die Gefahr hin, mich zu wiederholen.
Aber ich liebe ihr Produkt. Auf die Gefahr hin, mich zu wiederholen. Aber ich liebe ihr Produkt. Auf die Gefahr hin,
mich zu wiederholen.
Die ganze Familie.
Ey Leute, wir bringen ein T-Shirt raus, wo dieser komplette
Mailverkehr einfach abgedruckt ist.
Wir lieben das Produkt.
Liebe Grüße.
Aus dem sonnigen. Ne, jetzt ist es regnerisch vielleicht, aus dem windigen, aus dem windigen Köln, Familie Tietze. So, sehr schön. Jetzt das Bild hier rein. Grossartig. Wenden. So, sehr schön. Ich bin sehr gespannt, was zurückkommt. Aber, ich meine, ja. Naja, wenn man nicht mehr mit einer Antwort rechnet von Esty Johnson & Son, kommt halt doch noch eine Antwort. Grossartig. . Aber ganz kurz, wir müssen kurz Ärzt werden, wir sind manchmal ernst, und zwar jetzt, weil uns haben schlechte Nachrichten erreicht und manchmal muss man ja auch sich an die eigene Nase fassen, das ist ja einiges.
oder Schnabel.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das angebracht ist.
Wir sind manchmal ernst, Stefan.
Also, Folgendes ist passiert.
Wir haben ja in der letzten Zeit uns,
und da sehen wir wirklich sehr, sehr viel Nachholbedarf bei uns,
und da möchten wir uns auch noch mal zutiefst entschuldigen. Wir haben leider eine kleine Odyssee an Missverständnissen hinter uns. Und deswegen möchten wir hier noch mal uns entschuldigen. Es tut uns leid. Es tut uns sehr leid.
Diese Woche
sind wegen uns und wegen
unseren Tipps, die wir geben,
unseren Servicetipps
vier
Schwäne verendet.
Vier Schwäne sind verendet,
denn sie wurden falsch gefüttert,
sie wurden mit Brot gefüttert, das A,
Römisch erstens, schon vergammelt war oder römisch b.
Sagt du vielleicht mal das Schild vorlesen.
Uns hat ein Bild erreicht.
Ja, ich bin völlig, ich bin nicht so durcheinander.
Du bist mit der Frage.
Uns hat ein Bild erreicht aus dem Friedhof Ohlsdorf, liebe Gäste.
Vor einer Weile gab es ihr, man muss sich vorstellen, es ist dieser typische Kundenstopper und dann rechts neben ist ein riesen Ausrufezeichen.
Stellt euch das grösste Ausrufezeichen. Und das auf einem Friedhof, wo man sich denkt, wow, was ist hier passiert? Ja, genau. Das einzige, wo ich jetzt irgendwie das nicht erwarten würde. Die Messler ist hoch, weil sehr viele tote Menschen da begraben sind. Das stimmt. Also wir können entweder Scheiße, wir haben deinen Opa verloren, oder Zombies. Zombies, ja, es gibt nur diese beiden Möglichkeiten. Liebe Gäste, komm ein bisschen runter, die Stimmung ist ein bisschen zu gelöst.
Liebe Gäste, vor einer Weile gab es hier vier Jungschwäne.
Leider sind sie alle gestorben.
Die gehen echt rein, die gehen direkt rein.
Die haben ja im Friedhof, die haben nichts zu verstecken, die wissen, dass schlechte Nachrichten kommen.
Da wird jetzt nichts Positives kommen.
Der Grund ist traurig. Auch dieser Satz fehlt am Platz am Friedhof.
Besucher haben Brot an die Schwäne
verfüttert. Sie haben Brot in den Teich
geworfen, das schon verdorben war.
Oder im Wasser verdorben ist.
Die Schwäne sind dann an der Vergiftung
zugrunde gegangen. Unterlassen
sie daher dringend das Füttern aller Tiere,
ihr Friedhof Olsdorf.
Mir fehlt das typische Team.
Ihr Friedhof Olsdorf Team.
Ganz kurz, rewind. Lebt ein Friedhof nicht davon, dass Sachen sterben? Hat der da nicht selber auch von profitiert? Wo sind die jetzt begraben? Liebe Gäste, eigentlich finden wir es ganz geil. Ja, auch wenn sie es vielleicht nicht erwarten würden. Ich hab immer im Kopf bei diesen Grabaushebern, so nennt man die, habe ich im Kopf diesen Typen von Lucky Luke,
der sich immer gefreut hat, wenn Leute gestorben sind,
der schon bei jedem Duell daneben stand, sich so rangeschlichen hat und schon mit einem Schaufel in der Hand bewaffnet war, darauf aus, direkt das nächste Grab auszuheben. Den stelle ich mir vor. Der hat das mit seiner Sense so reingemalt auf dieses Blatt Papier. Ja, genau. Aber die Wahrheit ist ernst. Und da möchten wir jetzt auch keine Witze machen. Es sind tatsächlich vier Jungschwäne verendet. Schwäne sind Ententiere, Entenwesen. Entenvögel. Entenwesen. Geht uns das natürlich besonders nahe. Und deswegen noch mal, ganz kurz, Leute, wir müssen das alles noch mal zusammenfassen. Entenwesen? Bitte Enten. Nicht mit Brot füttern, auf gar keinen Fall mit Nudeln füttern, sondern ausschließlich mit Reis füttern. Und jetzt auch keine Schwäden. Schwäne. Keine Schwäden, keine Schwäne, bitte nur Enten mit Reis füttern, alles andere bitte unterlassen. Niemals Entenwesen auf irgendeine Art füttern, ausser mit Reis. Auch wenn sie sehr hungrig aussehen und bellen oder nach euch dann so. Und wie gesagt, vielleicht, vielleicht Gummibärchen. Das ist noch nicht klar. Es ist noch nicht klar. Das Labor hat noch nicht geantwortet leider. Ihr müsst es noch nicht lassen. Ja, ja. Macht es mal weiter, wir falsifizieren das Ganze. Richtig, richtig. Erst mal alles füttern, bis auf die Sachen, die wir gesagt haben. Also, wenn ihr Enten was Gutes tun wollt, nehmt eine Packung Uncle Ben's mit und da ist genug für alle da und dann kriegt jeder, was er haben will. Man soll auch Hunde, ich hab nämlich damals, bei uns gab's jeden Freitag abends gab's so traditionsmäßig Hähnchen. Schön, halbes Hähnchen. Jeden Abend?
Jeden Abend und jeden Mittag
gab es schön vom Hähnchen.
Traditionell.
Ich habe in dem Hähnchenwagen gewohnt.
Jeden Freitagabend gab es bei uns Hähnchen.
Manchmal auch Pizza, meistens Hähnchen.
Oder Fischstäbchen.
Oder aber auch, es gab immer was anderes.
Und dann habe ich jeden Freitag
die Knochen genommen und den Hunden auf den Schotterweg geworfen. Bis irgendwann eine Meute ankam mit Fackeln und Heugabeln, die auf die Unheil gerufen hat und auf mich zugelaufen ist. Tüze! Nein! So bist das! Und dann haben die auf diesen zwölfjährigen Jungen mit diesen großen Augen und diesem Beutel aus Knochenbeutel angeschrien, wie es sein kann, weil Hunde daran, weil die sind gekocht ja, selbstverständlich.
Hunde?
Knochen, Äntchenknochen sind gekocht.
Gekocht?
Ja, die kochen fast.
Gebacken.
Gebacken, gekocht.
Äntchen werden auch nicht gekocht. Ja, aber die Flüssigkeit darin kocht, so heiß ist das ja. Im Knochen? Ich weiß es nicht. Was hat der Mob geschrien? Was hat der Mob dir erklärt in lauter Sprache? Die haben alle gleichzeitig geschrien, deswegen war es etwas schwierig zu verstehen, hat sie gesagt. Und dann haben sie jedenfalls gesagt, dass dadurch, dass die Knochen so heiß geworden sind, dass sie zersplittern und deswegen Hunde daran sterben. Heißt, irgendwann hat Carmen keine Hunde mehr gehabt. Und diese Geschichte wiederholt sich gerade. Also wenn wir von dem Entensterben, für das wir verantwortlich sind zum Teil, sprechen, da habe ich mal so ein paar Flashbacks. Also du musst mich entschuldigen, wenn ich dann teilweise in die Tränen komme, weil ich das Ganze schon mal durchgemacht habe, weil wegen mir sehr viele Hunde gestorben sind. Aber sind wirklich Hunde gestorben oder ...?
Auf gar keinen Fall niemals Hunde mit Hähnchenknochen,
gebackenen Hähnchenknochen füttern.
Fressen denn Hunde Knochen oder ...?
Die kauen darauf rum.
Und die saugen das Mark raus.
Aber dann zersplittert das.
Aber die machen das, um das Mark rauszusaugen.
Nee, ist wie bei Katzen, die mit Mäusen ja auch nur spielen,
spielen die mit den H mit den Knochen.
Ich weiß es nicht. Ich weiß es nicht. Eine kurze Gedenkminute, wir hätten jetzt die vier Namen der verstorbenen Jungschwäne vorlesen, In Gedenken.
Top vier gestorben Jungschwäne vorlesen, in Gedenken, die Top 4 gestorbene Jungschwäne in einer geschmackvollen Top-Vier-Liste. Flop vier. Auf Platz Nummer vier, Fedi. Auf Platz Nummer drei, Antoine. Auf Platz Nummer zwei. Achter Schwan. Und auf Platz Nummer eins. Schwan. Unsere Herzen sind bei euch. Schwan, Schwan. Unsere Gedanken gehören euch. Und wir sagen sorry. Sorry. Ihr habt auch nicht alles richtig gemacht. Nee, das muss man sagen. Aber ihr hättet trotzdem nicht so früh sterben sollen, Stefan. Ihr hättet trotzdem nicht so früh sterben sollen. Dann ist man da manchmal in Oldsdorf langgegangen und dann haben die manchmal auch sehr laut, haben auch ein bisschen die Totenruhe gestört. Was ist denn eigentlich, also sorry, jetzt wo wir das abgehakt haben, was ist denn los mit Schwähen eigentlich? Hatte nicht jetzt auch erst dieser 187-Straßenbanden-Typ, der gab so eine Schlagzeile, hat den Strassenschwan geschlagen und beleidigt als Hurensohn? Ah, Jesus! Ja? Ich dachte, der heißt Jesus! Jesus! Ernsthaft, verarscht ihr mich gerade? Jesus! Ich dachte, Jesus! Genau! Was? Jesus! Ich glaube, der meint schon Jesus, aber es ist alle, ich glaube, der heißt Jesus. Ist ein Rapper. Ja, ein Rapper. Ein Sprachkünstler, Sprachgesangkünstler. Flotte Sprache. Und der hat einen Schwan geschlagen und da hieß es in der Schlagzeile, als Hurensohn beleidigt. Und ich mir denke, kann man Tiere beleidigen Nee, der Schwan hat ihn als Hurensohn beleidigt. Ich glaube, das ist... Und dann kann man die anderen als diesem Schwan einfach... Ich verstehe es ein bisschen. Ja, ja, ja. Weil die diesen langen Hals haben. Ja, ja, ja. Und einfach dieser Schlag in die Fresse des Schwans. Ja. Ich will sehen, was der Hals macht. Weichen die aus oder haben die so einen Rückfell? Tut dem das weh? Hat der Halswirbel? Fragen, Fragen, Fragen. Ich glaube, es ist auch einfach ein unbewusster Neid auf diesen langen Hals. Keiner mag Giraffen. Alle lieben Giraffen. Weil man neidisch ist. Es ist, glaube ich, so was, im Grunde schwingt dann Hass mit auf Schwäne. Aber ich bin auch nicht gut, auf Schwäne zu sprechen. Das bringt mein Flop-E Flop-Eins Funfact, das schlechteste Funfact ist, Giraffen haben auch nur sieben Halswirbel, weil jeder Zoo macht diesen Fehler, dass überall in diesem Giraffenhaus steht diese lustige, große Frage immer, wie viele Wirbel hat ein Giraffenhals und tut, erwartet so, als ob man auf die Antwort, als ob man ausflippt, als ob man diese Antwort nicht fassen kann. Ja. Und dass die nicht in den Kopf reingeht. Und überall auch immer in diesen ganzen komischen Shows, die von Frank Elster noch moderiert werden, in den dritten Programmen. Wie Gald-Bohning-Shows. Typische Wie Gald-Bohning-Sitz-da-Rumpf-Shows. Ja. Wird auch immer diese Frage gestellt. Und immer sagen alle What? Kann ich zeigen, dass die auch nur sieben Halswirbel haben.
Weil der ist ja länger.
Der ist ja viel länger. Aber das ist wirklich der eine Fakt, den schon mittlerweile jeder mindestens achtmal gehört hat.
Und dass man da auch noch so tun muss, als ob man das beeindruckt, finde ich sehr fragwürdig.
Aber die einzelnen Wirbel sind dann auch länger. Oder hat er dann so Quatsch zwischen den Wirbeln oder was?
Wie, wie länger?
Nee, der hat ja einen längeren Hals, also sind die Wirbeln länger. Die sind größer, auch höher, die Wirbel. Auch breiter? Das macht schon, es ist ja auch immer noch interessant. Ich finde lustig, dass oft die Häuser in Zoos, wo die Tiere drinstehen, die den Tieren lustigerweise sehr angepasst sind. Das Giraffenhaus ist einfach immer hoch. Es ist nicht wirklich breiter. Ja, es sieht auch aus wie die Giraffe. Es sieht aus wie eine große Giraffe. Ihr hört es wieder, ich habe keinen Pop-Schutz. Aber wenn es euch jemanden in acht Wochen nicht mehr stört, dann haben wir auch Pop-Schutze abgeschafft. Braucht man nicht? Weiß ich nicht, aber sorry, wir haben die nicht mehr gefunden. Aber ich finde es erstaunlich, wie das Verhältnis Hals zu Beinen zustande kommt. Also die haben ja so einen langen Hals, weil die Sachen fressen wollen, die hoch oben sind. Stimmt, aber die haben auch lange Beine. Die hätten ja genauso gut einen ganz normalen Pferdehals haben können. Aber noch längere Beine. Aber dreimal so lange Beine. Also woher, warum legt sich das fest, wo der Bauch ist? Ich habe irgendwann in der Evolution gesagt, lächerlich. Das sieht jetzt albern. Das sieht jetzt albern, das sieht quatschig aus. Die hatten auch erst einen sehr, sehr langen Hals, aber ungefähr so hohe Beine wie ein Pferd. Das war auch weird, glaube ich. Da gab es auch kurz mal eine Brainstorming-Runde, wo gesagt wurde, hier kommt das auch albern. Und da hat man beides überkompensiert, in beide Richtungen, einiges auf die Mitte. Sehr lange Beine, sehr langer Hals. Und dann lass es noch mal eine Generation machen, kurze Beine, kurzer Hals, langer Körper. Langer Körper. Wie so ein Geist. Aber trotzdem nur sieben Halswirbel. Das ist klar. Immer sieben Halswirbel. Das ist klar. Also da müssen wir überhaupt nicht drüber reden. Eine Frage noch. Auch bei langem Hals sieben Halswirbel. Immer sieben. Das ist klar. War unnötig die Frage, aber ich wollte sicher gehen. Nee, das ist völlig klar. Ich glaube, wenn man die Evolution der Giraffe sich anschaut, ist die immer gleich groß, nur die Position des Bauches schwingt so von oben nach unten, so eine Sinuskurve, dass man sich nicht entscheiden kann. Es hat wieder was von Cursor bei Sims, dass man erst, auch wenn man die Breite des Körpers auswählen könnte. Erst mal ganz dick, ganz dünn, und irgendwann ist man in die Mitte gegangen. Es ist immer die Mitte. Es ist immer die Mitte. Das ist auch eine Regel, finde ich, für diese Welt. Es ist immer die Mitte. Ich bin nicht reich, ich bin nicht arm, ich bin die Mitte. Ich bin nicht zu gross, mein Penis ist nicht zu klein, es ist die Mitte. Es ist immer die Mitte. Es ist nicht immer die Mitte. Du bist ja gross, Stefan. Was? Das wurde dir auch schon... Du bist nicht Mitte, du bist gross. Du bist sehr gross. Übergross. Die Regel ist Quatsch. Übergross, Stefan. Zu gross. Kannst du gut klettern? Nee. Das ist auch Evolution. Grosse Menschen können nicht gut klettern, kleine Menschen können nicht klettern. Im Gegenwart meines Daseins, in meiner Gegenwart, hätte man auch sagen können, wurde gesagt neulich, ja, übrigens auch bei der Serie, man castet ja meistens nur kleine Menschen, deswegen sind auch die ganzen Schauspieler so klein, Tom Cruise und so, weil deren Körper proportional aussehen.
Und das ganze Meeting hat dann
kurz so einen Moment gehabt, wo es zu mir gekommen ist.
Aber es ist vieler Satz,
was die meisten,
viele Hollywood-Schauspieler,
sei es Tom Cruise,
Keanu Reeves, diese typischen
Default-Action-Stars,
sind alle kleiner. Und ich habe ja auch mal gefragt, warum das so ist. Weil klein ist ja kein Schönheitsideal. Aber die Grösse, du hast ja einen Einfluss auf, wie die Grösse wirkt in dem Film. Du kannst die Möbel kleiner machen. Genau, du framest ja das Bild. Und alle Häuser sind dann ein bisschen kleiner. Die kriegen dann halt so kleine Stifte. Godzilla war nicht so groß. Nee. Die haben einen kleinen Godzilla genommen und haben die Stadt dann rum kleiner gebaut. Und weil die Körper sehen proportional aus bei Leuten wie Tom Cruise und Ken Reeves. Die haben sehr schöne, proportionale Körper. Die Körper sehen proportional aus. Okay, verstehe. Genau. Das heißt bei... Bei mir ist es nicht proportional. Ja. Man sieht so aus... Aber was heißt das denn proportional? Ja, meine Arme sehen zu lang aus, wenn ich sitze. Dann sieht alles ein bisschen falsch aus, weil du das nicht im Kontext siehst die ganze Zeit. Ja, ja. Als Ganzkörperbild bin ich auch ein normaler Mensch, wo ja auch wahrscheinlich proportional alles okay ist. Ah ja. Aber so für sich genommen, wenn man nur mal einen Ausschnitt meines Gesichts sieht, denkt man pfff. Ja, Moment, aber heißt das nicht im Umkehrschluss, dass einfach die Welt zu groß ist? Zu klein ist für mich. Nee, zu groß ist, weil wenn die Menschen extra kleiner gemacht werden müssen, man könnte auch einfach sagen, alle Tische fünf Prozent kleiner, alle Stühle fünf Prozent kleiner, dann wird sich das Problem wieder lösen, weil dann wirken die nämlich nicht mehr besser. Nee, dann wirken sie auch unproportional.
Dann wirken die normalen,
grossen. Ja, damit die Leute wie ich spielen, Schauspielern können, müssten wir
einfach auch größere Tische haben,
größere Stühle, das ganze Spiel.
Naja, es ist schwierig.
Aber da habe ich kurz erwischt gefühlt.
Das ist aber auch
immer ein Gag.
Keine Rothaarigen, auf gar keinen Fall.
Rothaarige kommen nicht gut an, die sehen nicht gut aus. Immer der eine Rothaarige Autor. Ja, das stimmt schon. Ja, klar, das muss nicht machen. Das ist klar, das stimmt schon. Ich war auch jetzt in dem neuen Film Hereditary. Eine große Empfehlung für diesen Film. Der neue A24-Film, die machen ja eh nur fantastische Filme. Ach, hört mal auf. Und da gibt's eine Tochter, die als sehr unangenehm gecastet wurde. Ja. Da wurde einfach ein hässliches Mädchen gecastet. Naja. Wie steht das im Buch? Steht da im Drehbuch ein hässliches Mädchen? Aber das ist ja auch ein bisschen Teil der Rolle. Die muss ja einem Suspekt sein. Naja, die ist nicht hässlich. Die wird ja auch so inszeniert. Nee, aber ich hab einen Trailer gesehen und ich hab aber auch gesehen, dass diese Schauspielerin davor auch schon andere Sachen gemacht hat, die macht zum Beispiel auch Musicals und so. Und wenn man sich da Sachen anschaut, dann fällt das gar nicht so sehr auf. It's hard not life for us! Dann fällt das gar nicht so stark auf. Die sieht ja auch so ein bisschen weird aus, weil die so inszeniert wird, weil die auch immer so leer schaut. Okay, festbleibt, aber es wird auf jeden Fall, werden doch Leute manchmal nach schlechtem Aussehen gecastet. und die sind sehr gut gecastet. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ja, das stimmt schon. Aber es kommt natürlich auch darauf an, also wenn du dir zum Beispiel ein Interview mit der anschaust, dann wirkt die recht normal. Also du nimmst dir natürlich immer schon wahr, so oh, wie sieht die in echt aus? Da wirkt die nicht verflucht oder so. Ich glaube nicht, dass, ich glaube, der Fluch wurde abgewählt. Die muss ja ein verfluchtes Mädchen gecastet haben. Ja, das stimmt schon. Das ist ja allen klar. Ja, ja. Guck dich diesen Film an. Aber es ist halt wirklich so, du... Hey! Hey! Komm doch ruhig rein. Ja, klar. Oh, guck mal, jetzt haben wir einen großen Gast hier. Hey, Darius! Hallo, Darius! Wir nehmen gerade einen Podcast auf, ist es okay? Mensch! Ja, klar. Hi, warum hast du denn so in den Raum geschielt? Hi. Hi! Ich gebe dir mal die. Warum hast du denn so in den Raum geschielt?
Weil ich euch nicht stören wollte.
Aber du wolltest doch gucken, wer hier gerade in dem Raum ist.
Ich hätte deine Stimme gehört und dazu, okay, das muss ein Podcast sein, ich will jetzt nicht stören.
Aber du hast genau das getan dann.
Auf euren Wunsch hin. Wir freuen uns immer sehr auf dich.
Was ist denn Raum beurteilt?
Warum hast du das die Decke angeguckt?
Die Lampen wollte ich fotografieren.
Was? Okay, dann. Die Lampen. Bitte. Ich habe so ein Sammelsurium an Lampen. Magst du Lampen gern? Diese Lampe mag ich besonders gerne. Das sind einfach... Wir haben jetzt eine so grosse Wohnung, dass wir nicht genau wissen, äh... Wir haben nach einem Balkon gesucht, fünf Jahre ohne Balkon, und jetzt haben wir einen Garten. Oh, schönen Grillen erstmal. Nee, aber so einen geteilten Garten. Geil. Was? Ja. Schön Grillen. Da musst du aber viel Arbeit reinstecken, ne? Ja, aber ich bin auch so ein Gemüse... Du bist ein Gemüse-Typ. Ich bin in so einer Kommune aufgewachsen, so ein Bio wie im Kliemannsland im Meer. Wirklich? Genau das Gleiche eigentlich. Okay. Das heißt, ich kenne körperliche Arbeit. Sehr gut. Finde ich so schlecht. Schlecht. Machst du mal eine Grillparty? Gerne. Ihr kommt? Ja, mach mal. Okay. Viel Spaß. Ciao, ciao. Ciao. Ich habe eine Nachricht bekommen, und ich war noch nie stolz auf eine Nachricht. Und zwar gebe ich ja manchmal Finanztipps.
Und jetzt? Ja, tatsächlich, habe ich ein paar Mal gegeben. Ich habe zum Beispiel gesagt, dass... Einmal habe ich gesagt, Tesla-Aktien, einmal habe ich gesagt, geht es auf gar keinen Fall Aktien kaufen, weil der Markt bricht zusammen. Und einmal habe ich gesagt, Time Warner-Aktien. Folgende Nachricht hat uns erreicht von Simon Peters. Nachdem Tietze aka Gordon Gekko schon den den größten Kursverlust der Wall Street vorausgesagt hat, lag er auch mit Time Warner richtig. Seit seiner Empfehlung ist die Aktie um mehr als 10% gestiegen. Das war vor drei Wochen oder sowas. Und Florentin, Elefanten haben auf den Rücken und Kopf borsten. Grüße an euch beide. Okay. Interessant war es für unterschiedliche Nachrichten. Naja, daran sieht man... Ja, ich hab mich sehr gefreut. Aber er hat wahrscheinlich keine Warner Brothers Aktien gekauft, sondern nur beobachtet. Ich hab welche gekauft, aber. Ja und, Cash Cash Cash oder was? Ja, zehn Prozent. Geil. Ist es nicht Cash Cash Cash? Naja. So Cash halt. Naja, ein bisschen Cash. Auch gut. Ja, ja, auch gut. Naja, aber das hat mich sehr gefreut. Ihr merkt, ihr lacht zwar immer, aber es ist schon auch manchmal purer Ernst. Da möchte ich meine Finanztipps auch mal raushauen. Nämlich alles, was mit Augenmedizin zu tun hat. Lasertechnik, Vielmann, Onlineversand, nein, Onlineversand, Optikertechnikik, alles was mit Augenerkrankungen zu tun hat, wird boomen in der nächsten Zeit. Warum? Denn die Zahl an sehgestörten Menschen nimmt rapide zu, weil die alle nur in der Dunkelheit auf ihr Smartphone gucken. Und in Asien, in den asiatischen Jugendlichen brauchen 90% eine Brille. Hast du eine Ahnung, was das für ein Markt ist? Hallo? Brillen. Die ganzen Asiaten. Aber erst mal Brillen. Und in Deutschland auch. Die brauchen alle Brillen oder eine Augenoperation. Und da wird schön reinfinanziert. Kann man jetzt einfach so, kann ich jetzt hier bei Aktien ein Suchfeld oben eingeben? Nee, aber du kannst in deiner Bank gehen und dir da so ein Ding zusammenschnüren lassen. So ein paar Lasertechnik-Sachen, ein paar Optikertechniken. Nein, natürlich nicht, aber ich meine nur Finanztipps, du gibst ja Finanztipps nicht für dich, Apollo oder so ein Brillenstartup, Apollo Optik, Apollo Bankkorb, Apollo Investment, zeig mal, wie sieht der Aktienkurs aus von Apollo, ne, das ist Apollo Bankkorb, das kann man jetzt nicht sehen, das ist wahrscheinlich nicht die Firma, ja guck mal, hoch. Ja, geht hoch. Also ich sag's nur, Leute, falls ihr euch wundert, warum ihr kein Geld habt, dann weil ihr nicht auf meine Tipps geachtet. Hier, Lasermaster International. Ja, Lasermaster. Lasermaster, ich gucke auch gar nicht mehr, was es ist, es klingt cool, kaufen. Also die nächste Empfehlung, Lasermaster International. Lasermaster wird steigen.
Ehrlich gesagt, jede Firma, die Lasermaster heißt, hat verdient, Laser Kings, sowas hat verdient zu steigen.
Du weißt, dass es von Leuten gegründet wurde, die haben kein Gespür für PR, das heißt, sie müssen irgendwas anderes gut können, wie zum Beispiel Laserkanonen bauen.
Es ist aber auch nicht sowas, wie Firmen gründen. Also das würde ich jetzt auch nicht in denen unterstellen, als Top-Quality. Naja. Naja. Man weiß es nicht. Was ist deine grösste Angst? Deine grösste Angst? Ich glaube, würde ich, dass meine Augen zu lang werden. Zu lang werden? Ich habe in diesem Artikel gelesen, dass die Augen werden immer länger. Was ist mit Augen? Du hast auch so ein Augenproblem. Ja, ich habe eine krasse Augenphobie, Augenproblem. Aber Augen werden tatsächlich immer länger und dadurch wird es unscharf. Und das Problem, viele dachten ja immer daran, es liegt daran, dass man zu lange auf Bildschirme schaut. Einfach weil man nicht so oft in die Ferne guckt, sondern immer nah. Aber Forscher haben herausgefunden, dass die Distanz gar nicht so ausschlaggebend ist, sondern die Helligkeit. Dass das Problem ist, wenn du in Dunkelheit zu lange auf den Bildschirm schaust, dann werden die Auge lang, weil die dann so, ich will wissen. Auge lang, das sagst du immer so, als wäre es ein Gag, aber es ist nicht ernst. Nein, die werden lang, die werden länger. Da wird der Augapfel, der ist ja kreisrund und dadurch wird durch die Linse, wird das Licht perfekt auf die Netzhaut geworfen, aber wenn der sich verformt. Das Auge will sehen und das Auge kneift auch das Auge zusammen. Also das Auge rückt so immer wieder nach vorne. Das Auge macht große Augen im Grunde. Und dann wird es immer länger, weil so, was ist das, was ist das? Das kann ich nicht mehr kennen. Und dadurch ist es unscharf, weil dieser Brennpunkt des Lichts dann nicht mehr auf der Netzhaut liegt. Und steht sich dann auch selber im Wege. Ja, das stimmt. Das stimmt, ja. Und deswegen schaut wirklich, wenn es hell ist, geht raus und schaut draußen auf dem Bildschirm. Und vor allem, was in dem Artikel stand. Darius recht, Lampen. Darius hat vor allem recht mit dem Garten, nicht mit den Lampen, künstliches Licht zählt nicht, mit dem Garten, dann liest er sein Buch im Hefrauen. Und was in diesem Artikel stand, was man dagegen machen kann, ist im Hellen in die Ferne schauen. Das heißt, wenn ihr euch Angst habt um eure Augen, dann setzt euch einfach zwei Stunden am Tag raus und schaut in die Ferne. Aber nicht in die Sonne. Nicht in die Sonne. Auf gar keinen Fall in die Sonne, aber in die Ferne. Aber ich stelle mir so besorgte Eltern vor, die sagen, mein Kind ist die ganze Zeit im Dunkeln, macht die Rollladen zu. Jeden Sonntag von 17 bis 18 Uhr wird in die Ferne geschaut. Herr Tram, du schaust jetzt bis heute Abend, bis Pink Panther schaust du jetzt in die Ferne. Okay. Erstmal, erst mal, yay. Nein, nicht in Fernsehen. Ah ja. In die Ferne. In die Ferne. Und dann schaut das Kind so wirklich wie so ein Kapitän auf Landsuche, einfach so in die Ferne den ganzen Tag. Genau. Sieht man so Landschaft, und im Winter sieht man ganz viele Menschen, so Silhouetten von Menschen, die einfach in die Ferne kommen. Ja, aber vielleicht ist es auch so ein evolutionäres Ding, dass man Feinde erkennt oder Raubtiere, dass die, die immer nur so vor sich hingucken, auf dem Boden gucken, die kriegen lange Augen und sterben, und die, die immer den Horizont beobachten und wissen, ah, was ist das, was ist das hinten, die überleben. Die kriegen lange Augen. Das sagst du jetzt immer so, als ob das der wissenschaftliche Begriff dafür ist. Die Augen werden lange. Du kriegst lange Augen, wenn du dunkler als jetzt. Pass auf, Kollege, wenn du so weitermachst, Freundchen, hör mal, wenn du so weitermachst, Kollege, dann... Kriegst du lange Augen. Kriegst du, dann kriegst du lange Augen. Ich habe letztens das aus ausgefunden, wie man Hopsa-Lauf schreibt. H-O-P-S-A. Hopsa. Hopsa-Lauf. Nee, mit E-R. Hopsa-Lauf. Ah, Hopsa-Lauf, dieser, wenn man, wenn dein Song auf der Tanzfläche kommt und du auf die Tanzfläche läufst, weil du dann mit tanzen willst. It's hard not. Nein, direkt Hopsa-Lauf. Warum hat der Mensch also, warum kann der Mensch so verschiedene Lauftechniken? Also beim Pferd ist es ja ganz krass, das hat ja wirklich verschiedene Laufmodi. Also auch so von der Abfolge der einzelnen Hufe, die auf dem Boden kommen. Aber das ist ja Quatsch, hat das ja nicht. Doch, hat es schon. Das gibt man dem ja nur. Aber ich weiß es nicht. Galopp ist ja eins, zwei, drei, vier. Die schon, dass sich in freier Bildbahn nicht zu Musik in einem perfekten Rechteck bewegen. Na, aber die haben schon so, oh, jetzt aber, und dann laufen sie schnell und so. Ich glaube, schnell laufen die echt anders. Ja, das meine ich ja. Dass es nicht nur einfach ein beschleunigter, normaler Gang ist, sondern dass es auch ein ganz anderer Gang ist. Trab und Galopp. Ja, das stimmt. So Leoparden. Ich stand nicht am Entengehege, sondern primär am Leopardengehege. Und da ist mir aufgefallen, dass sobald die zurennen auf dich, ich bin dann ins Gehege gegangen, klar, sobald die zurennen auf dich, haben die nicht mehr diesen Rechts-Links-Gang, sondern die haben nur vorne-hinten Gang.
Weißt du? Die nehmen dann...
Ja, Galopp, glaube ich.
Ist das Galopp?
Ich glaube, wenn du wirklich so die rausschwingst...
Genau, genau.
Sehr, sehr schwer in einem Podcast zu betreiben.
Die Hinterbeine schwingen nach vorne, die Vorderbeine schwingen nach hinten.
Aber abwechselnd. Also nicht so, dass sie die einfach einmal nach hinten tun und das war's.
Nee, nee.
Es gibt schon eine Rundbewegung.
Vielen Dank. Die Vorderbeine schwingen nach hinten. Aber abwechselnd. Also nicht so, dass sie die einfach einmal nach hinten tun und das war's. Nee, nee. Es gibt schon eine Rundbewegung. Es wiederholt sich. Wie einem Gif. Okay. Wir fassen zusammen. Nee, es stimmt schon. Es ist schon richtig, was du sagst. Stefan T. Hast du was vor im Sommer? Nee. Urlaub? Nee, das Zooding hat mich schon beeindruckt. Ich verlange mal wieder, vor allem der Kölner Zoo ist ganz cool, weil er genau in der Innenstadt ist. Das war echt weird, weil du hast halt, also du bist im Seehundgehege und direkt daneben beginnt, ist ein Wohnhaus. Ja. Das heißt, du hast einfach, stell mal vor, du wohnst mitten in Köln, das ist auch eine gute Wohngegend, mitten in Köln und direkt daneben, du kannst die ganze Zeit aufs Seehundgegel gucken, kriegst jeden Tag die coole Fütterung mit. Pünktlich um 15 Uhr werden die Seehunden gefüttert. Du kannst sie ja selber füttern. Bisschen Reis aus dem Fenster. Jeder alte Viertel oder alte Knochen vom Hähnchen einfach reinwerfen. Tietze!
Und dann hast du die ganze Sache, hast du dieses Arr, Arr, Arr.
Das geht ja auch tiefer. Das machen die aber auch nur, wenn Leute da sind, oder? Wenn die unter sich sind, dann machen die so, was geht's. Hey, hoi, ein guter Tag, Leute. Gute Show, Hubert. Danke, danke. Schönen Fisch zwischen die Flossen. Nee, du bist genau, weißt du, ich sehe das manchmal, dein Vorgänger hat das nicht gemacht, du bist genau durch den Ring. Weißt du, da kommt nichts, da kommt keine Finne, keine Flosse, keine Flippe, kommt mehr gegen den Ralf. Du bist da so durchgegriffen. Nee, da ist ja auch viel Glück dabei. Oh, der Ball, der Ball und die Susi. Na ja, das ist halt. Oh, die Susi ist schon, ne? Wie die den Ball auf der Nase massiert? Na ja. Oh, da kommen Leute. Es klingt so ein bisschen, als würden die sich selbst imitieren. Als würden die behinderte Seehund imitieren. Ja, oh, wir machten Seehund. Und wenn man sich das verselbstständigt, dann klangen die halt einfach so und kamen nicht mehr raus aus dem Gag, wenn der Gag zu weit geht. Ich habe mich gehasst in diesem Zoo. Warum? Dann bin ich rumgelaufen und dann gehst du zum Gehegen und ich dachte, ich bin
ein besserer Mensch. Aber ich gehe
zum Gehege und das Erste, was ich an jedem
Gehege mache, ist den Namen
des Tieres sagen, der in dem Gehege ist.
Du gehst zu dem Gehege und sagst
Ah, die Seehunde.
Und da stehen ja dann schon sehr viele Menschen.
Und wenn du selber
an einem Gehege stehst und du guckst die Kapuziner-Elfchen an, dann kommt neben der Familienvater, das sind immer die Veränderungen, die hingehen und sagen, ah, die Kapuziner-Elfchen. Und dann guckt man sich auch schon so und sagt, ernsthaft. Man ist aber selber auch nicht besser. Man geht immer zu dem Gehege und man sagt immer den Namen des Tieres. Ja. Ah, Nason. Ah. Klar. Kaffe. Ja. Es ist, glaube ich, etwas aus der Kindheit so antrainiert. Weil als Kind lernst du die Sprache primär durch Tiere. Einfach, dass die immer, oh, hier ist ein Graffe. Wem will ich was beweisen? Kinder mögen Tiere. Ich glaube, das ist einfach so angeboten. Ich glaube, letztlich willst du deine Eltern stolz machen. Aber wem will ich beweisen, dass ich das Nashorn erkannt habe? Deinen Eltern, du willst es, du willst deine Eltern stolz machen. Man geht zu dem Gehege, es steht auf dem Gehege.
Aal.
Man sieht es, was es ist, dass es der Starthorn ist.
Ja.
Wem an diesem Gehege will ich jetzt beweisen, dass ich bald das Tier erkannt habe?
Ähnliches Phänomen, ich, wirklich, ich gebe dir 10.000 Euro, wenn du jemals mit einer Gruppe Gleichaltrigen durch die Gegend läufst und man riecht Gras oder Marihuana und es sagt nicht einer, oh, es riecht mir so an Gras. Das ist wirklich ein Naturgesetz, das hätte Einstein so beschreiben können. Wenn eine Gruppe von Mittzwanzigern irgendwo hinläuft und es ist dieser Geruch, dann muss es jemand sagen. Wenn du merkst, die anderen sagen es nicht, dann sag du, dass du es. Genau, dann musst du es sagen. Aber wirklich, also für mich, also das ist schwer zu ergründen, aber es ist natürlich schon so ein Oh, ich kenne mich mit Drogen aus, das ist cool und ha ha ha oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Aber es ist wirklich so ein Drang, das muss ausgesprochen werden. Ich glaube, es ist auch so ein anderer Teil der Dinge. Weil wenn du einen Stamm riechst, der Gras raucht, ist er immer cooler als du. Genau. Und du bist nicht so cool, musst aber zumindest sagen, ah, ich kenne das, um zumindest noch einen Bruchteil der Coolness abzukriegen. Du willst aber auch nicht in Konkurrenz um Weibchen stehen mit dem cooleren Marihuana-Geruch. Weg, weg von denen. Weg, weg. Ja, also lass uns erst mal die Legalisierung von Gras nach hinten schieben. Für mich ist der viel wichtigere erste Schritt Abschaffung des Zwangs, es einfach zu erwähnen. Das stimmt. Man muss manchmal so Sachen sagen. Man hasst sich dann immer was sagen. Und auch wenn ich dann hier bei so einem Wetter rumlaufe und sage, oh, es ist warm. Das Erste, was ich mit Leuten sage, ist immer, es ist warm. Man ist ja unterm Strich auch nur ein dummer Mensch, der Dinge sagen muss. Oder du bist in der Gruppe unterwegs und es fängt an zu regnen. Jeder spürt das, aber es muss verbalisiert werden. Oh, es fängt an zu regnen. Jeder weiß das schon, aber es muss. Also stell dir mal die Situation vor, fünf Leute laufen nicht die Gegend, es fängt an zu regnen und sie gehen wortlos und geschlossen einfach irgendwo unter einen trockenen Bereich und warten da.
Das ist nicht machbar, das ist in der menschlichen Natur nicht vorgesehen.
Es muss, oh jetzt regnet es und erst dann kann was passieren.
Auch dann wird es schneller gegangen, es wird nichts an der Situation geändert.
Genau, es wird erst Realität in dem Moment, in dem es verbalisiert wurde. Auch Gewitter hat auch noch nie angefangen, ohne dass jemand sagt. Jetzt zieht es aber zu. Und erst dann darf es blitzen. Auch dann darf es erst zuziehen. Es darf nicht zuziehen, da darf jemand jemand sagen. Es ist eine Form von Magie, weil es ist auch eine Art Zauberspruch, die irgendwas bewirkt. Es muss ausgesprochen werden.
Das ist echt interessant. Jetzt kommt die Sonne raus.
Das ist total merkwürdig.
Jetzt kommt die Sonne wieder raus. Aber vor allem so Wetter, so Umstände, äussere Umstände, die man nicht beeinflussen kann auch.
Ich glaube, das ist ganz tief in der menschlichen Natur, dass der Mensch das irgendwie versucht zu kontrollieren, zu verzaubern.
Es gibt ja auch irgendwie so, dass man so Sachen sagen muss, um Unheil abzuwehren. Das ist da, glaube ich, immer noch mit verankert. Einfach, man muss es aussprechen. Es muss gesagt worden sein. Es muss gesagt werden. Aber das ist ein interessantes Experiment. Wenn es nicht anfängt zu regnen, einfach mal nichts sagen. Einfach nichts sagen. Und einfach mal beobachten, wer als erstes was sagt. Lass uns kurz unterstellen. Und das nächste Mal, wenn ihr Gras riecht, einfach mal nichts sagen. Einfach mal nicht, einfach, es ist ja nicht bemerkenswert als solches, es ist ja nichts Besonderes. Es muss nicht erwähnen werden. Macht's einfach nicht. Ja, also mindestens macht einer den Oh, ho, ho, ho. Ja, das ist so eine Semiverp, so Ho, ho, ho. Ja, genau. Es wird manchmal nicht ausgesprochen, aber... Wie schreibst du das in einem Skrämt? Oh, ho, hoohoho. Ja. Ohoho. Er macht die, ah, die Ries nach Grasgeste. Ohohoho. Klassische Ohohoho. So halb lachen, halb Ohohoho. Halb Ohohoho. Ey, falls euch noch mehrere Situationen einfallen, wo immer irgendjemand was unbedingt sagen muss, schreib's bitte in die Kommentare. Ja, dann machen wir nächste Woche mal eine Riesenliste. Wir machen eine Top 40 einfach mal. Fuck it. Das ist interessant, das ist wirklich interessant. Dinge, in denen man was sagen muss. Sei es am Zoo, wenn man am Gehege ankommt. Ein Esel. Sei es, wenn ein Gewitter aufzieht. Schreibt uns mal, wir machen eine große Liste. Jetzt kommt die Sonne wieder raus. Diese ganzen Sachen, die immer kommen. Auch der Zug, jetzt kommt er ein bisschen spät, zu spät, jeder weiss es, jeder sollte kommen.
Schreibt uns mal, es würde uns freuen und ansonsten hoffen wir, dass wir vielleicht eine Antwort bekommen und der Endenkrieg weitergeht.
Bis dahin, bitte, wenn ihr füttert, ausschliesslich mit Reis, wenn dann Reis, vielleicht mit Bärchen, Unkomite.
Reis, vielleicht mit Bärchen, Reis, vielleicht mit Bärchen, das mit.
Macht's gut, dann rein, bis zum nächsten Mal. Schöne Woche, wir haben ab.